In America,
who's got a Dick on his arm and he asked the doctors to put it there. Yeah.
It's what it is. He's got a Dick in his arm and apart,
apparently he's doing Japanese porn with it because they blurted it out.
Why did he, why did he put the Dick on his arm? What's the point?
Because why the? Not it's 2020. Why wouldn't you? Yeah,
he suffered a horrific infection in his paradigm that turned his fingers.
Toes in manhood black. Yeah. So he decided when I saw my penis go black,
I was besides myself. It was in a horror film because when his penis went black,
did it grow? Yeah. I don't know.
That was a stupid penis joke about like guys have a big penises.
I cannot believe it's racist that his penis turned black and then he cut it off.
That's racist. That is raised. But he dropped it. Yeah. I mean this kid, I mean,
this kid looks like a British kid.
This kid looks like he's on the runway anyway. Yeah. It's what,
he's 45 years old. He's your age? This kid's 45. Yeah.
He's he he's. Yeah. He's not in good shape for 45. He's not Greek is what it is.
He's also wearing filings basement. Adidas.
You always see what you can tell that the, the,
the cheap version of the Adidas that they got,
the filings basement store let's work. I'm ready to work. I am ready as well.
Just a little delay.
[Inaudible].
You better work on my West Elm stools.
I don't have to Yass anymore. I get all of the gay out where we work.
It's what it is. So let's lead it off with good vibrations. Toni Braxton.
One of my favorite singers reveal secrets or a flawless skin is a vibrator.
And she holds device to her face and it says bizarre video.
But I say it's holds her facing awesome video. I mean, here she is. Wow.
Uh, Tony haven't seen Tony in a while. She also lost all her money.
Some members she had lost all her money. That was a big story.
She gets made out of plastic too. If I'm going to be honest with you. Yeah.
I mean, if you want, I agree with you.
It looks like the girls had a few surgeries to really Botox down. Yeah.
Let's watch this video, but I do love Toni Braxton. Yeah. Oh, was mad enough.
Say you love me again. Hold on.
Hold on, hold on. Pause it for a second. I paused for a second.
I really want to see if me and you could try to sing good. You,
why don't you try one and then I'll try. I got some stuck in my throat. Okay.
I'll try. Uh, this is the best I can sing and break.
Say, you love me. Here
comes with the tears in your eyes. When you come into the net,
Hey, that's the best I can sing. I'm not lying. I wasn't doing that for,
yeah. Okay. This is what Tony said.
Tingler is this tingles the muscles in my face and get them activated and
working. I haven't used it or anything else other than my face. Okay. Just FYI.
I just take this and got the little ball here, which is perfect.
Sometimes I put it in the freezer is really cold.
I just kind of rub it and it just activate all those muscles.
Get them together. We are working today. We are going to be [inaudible].
Let's see what Sam has for me.
I named all my wigs.
So that's the look and I would suggest long hair. I love a nice hoot.
I think it kind of modernizes everything up to the face and like the Pokemon,
just a little bit supersede one and oldest, Toni Braxton.
Ready from what closeup? Mr.
Mr. Devel. [inaudible]
because this is the only morning show where your daughter wakes up and you have
to put on the movie that descendants live on the air. It's what it is.
I hope you enjoyed that episode of our morning show whereby the morning.
It's the morning show with full modeler bed, head, all that.
It's a little bump of Coke to start your day. Me and Chris,
the history hygienists.
We do the show live Monday through Friday 9:00 AM Eastern.
If you want to watch it live or get access to it every day,
go join a patrion.com/bay Ridge boys.
It's our channel sign up at the lowest tier level till July 1st.
And then it changes to the $10 level. Either way. Go now, go now.